malgré tout ce que je vous tiens je ne
vous laisse pas qu'est ce que vous
demandez moi qu'est ce que je vois
beaucoup de célébrités tout le temps m'a
demandé de passer la semaine avec moi
être mon assistante pour 10000 euros
pour la semaine entière vibre en prenant
une assistante
donc vous êtes fan de cheryl évidemment
et samassa m'a posé une question est ce
qu'il ya eu des demandes de fans un peu
particulière mois pendant qu'on m'a
demandé fast est une jeune femme pour
ses 40 ans elle voulait mois en cadeau
ouais ouais vous votre personne quoi
banon elle voulait ma présence en fait
j'étais en haut de l'escalier
c'est tout et est donc je veux arriver
et j'ai descendu l'escalier mais vous
êtes années passèrent qui avait un peu
hein
[Applaudissements]
c'était uk combien de zéros quelques-uns
quelques-uns des risques que vous avez
des demandes de fans un peu dingue mais
y en a un qui était une sorte de
fétichiste des pieds à g et en fait j'ai
dit c'est une photo en fait qui a
déclenché sa folie révèle beaupied une
photo avec lui ai envoyé cette photo
gallery à partir de la révocation
mais les noms mais les piétons que c'est
moi les pieds je suis très attentif les
pieds ah ouais bah c'est rédhibitoire
dans les petits bouillons tout le monde
les a seulement gelé d'autres pièges
qu'on se bouffe et d'autres c'est vrai
bien mais qu un mec un mec au collège
qu'on appelait crottes de nez il
mangeait ses pieds mais il était très
souple alors déjà oui m'enfin c'est sans
doute si c'était épique hill valley la
vallée du mali pendant des mois et des
glands toutes les semaines mme envoyé
une lettre en me disant je veux une
photo de vos pieds je venais fribourg
les faits bah non parce que jamais de la
vie
moi je me suis réellement la vie voilà
ça va les pieds bon certains marchés
[Rires]
moi j'ai des choses superbes loufoque
mais vraiment souvent mais y en a 1
depuis depuis quelques mois puis touche
pas à mon poste qui en fait me propose
de l'argent mais pour que je le tas pour
forcer ces annonces ont sapé la
constitution je pense qu'il est un peu
vous savez peut-être un peu se souvenir
ou quoi ouais il veut que je lui marche
dessus avec des talons que je lui donne
des gifles
il propose 2 d'apple est ce que vous
avez appelé la police c'est être gênée
elle voulait pas le faire mais ça va pas
non ce qui veut dire que vous le faut ça
normal non je vois ça normal mais c'est
une des choses qui existent depuis tout
voilà peut-être fait pas ça va passer en
douce calme et un maxi vous a demandé et
nous le disent que sur son plateau à
paris non parce que j'ai co organisé
pour que je le talk non non non
moi jamais suivi un reportage ou en fait
70 en angleterre et donc c'était une
maison une sorte de maison oui je débute
chose à oui en fait ce sont des hommes
alors souvent des hommes d'affaires jean
cac 40 c'est qu'ils venaient pour mettre
des couches se faire talk et et c'est
bien c'est un bon début du rapport
c'était il ya deux mois dans un grand
parc d'attractions je vais souvent le
week-end pour me payer une bonne tranche
de rire à mon avis vous adhérez là pour
mickey non mais bien sûr c'était pas ça
lavanant ferrer gêné par là dessus je me
promène tranquillement et là il ya un
couple quarantaine d'années qui viennent
mes gars me voit et la femme me demande
de faire prendre en photo à côté d'elle
d'accord elle se place à côté de moi
généralement elle mais on met les mains
sur les épaules sauf que là sa main
s'est déplacé directement sur mes fesses
ou alors je n'ai rien dit que ça faisait
longtemps qu il parte et elle revient
trois quatre minutes plus tard elle me
voit au fond elle me donne son numéro de
chambre elle m'invite elle son mari à le
rejoindre pendant la nuit
vous me connaissez vous avez pas été
j'ai du bon tabac bien sûr évidemment
merci fans étaient 140 x nous sommes en
novembre
[Rires]
l'air est suffocant dans le métro
parisien parce que nous sommes sur la
ligne 4 à l'heure de pointe citations
les jeunes femmes vient vers moi se
précipite dans la rame de métro avec son
téléphone à la main et me dit gilles ma
mère est femme de vous je viens de lui
dire que vous étiez dans la même rame
que moi ce que vous pouvez lui parler
moi je dis bien sûr je prends le
téléphone
bonjour madame etc je parle normalement
comme la la dame me dis mais c'est pas
votre voix vous n'êtes pas gilles verdez
jeudi mais si je vous assure elle me dit
faites comme verdez crier c'est un
scandale
donc je dis c'est un scandale dans la
rame de métro bondé ce n'est pas vous
donc je commence
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale et à
ce moment là tout le monde surtout dans
la rame de métro ont été obligés de
quitter la station cité et je continuais
sur le quai à crier c'est un scandale
madame magali tout ce que je vous tiens
je ne vous laisse pas qu'est ce que vous
demandez moi qu'est-ce qu'ils arrêtent
de demander pardon comme je vois
beaucoup de célébrités tout le temps m'a
demandé de passer la semaine avec moi
trop mon assistante pour 10000 euros
pour la semaine entière pour avoir une
assistante
oui mais c'est comme ça il voit en fait
toutes les célébrités etc et du coup
j'ai trouvé ça très sympa moi je n'ai
pas fait mais alors je suis pas sûr il
faut bien voilà c'était mon team et vous
bernard
alors moi c'est quand j'étais jeune et
beau il ya quand même une vingtaine
d'années j'étais exprès pour que vous
réagissez comme ça ben oui donc oui
merci
benji c'est pas très grand il est beau
je t'emmerde
j'ai soutenu les divines sur ton mec là
on voulait écraser les talents dont on
croit que c'est moi j'ai d'autres
déviations mais pas celle là alors alors
quand j'étais jeune
hier j'étais jeune donc j'avais nous on
a eu la chance d'avoir quelques fans etc
king et certaines très insistante
dirais-je en plus à l'époque j'avais lu
ni tabou vidéo gag et tout ça il se
trouve que vient la ville qui me dit tu
es vachement mignon tout ça je veux un
bébé de toi mais je te jure qu'elle a
été très très loin elle a trouvé mon
adresse est allé chez moi même été des
mots presque tous les jours dans la
boîte aux lettres j'attendrai c'est la
bonne période
on peut y aller alors oui c'est la nasa
oui c'est la nasse et un voulait un bébé
c'était à la fois gentil je n'ai pas
envoyé balader mais quand même un peu
après j'ai écrasé la tête mais c'est là
les garder le meilleur pour la fin
abon avant isabelle qu'est ce que vous a
demandé vous une nuit non c'est un
garçon qui va envoyer un message qui m'a
demandé une mèche de cheveux
donc ça va bon moi j'ai ouvert son
message mais je n'ai pas répondu
et comme il a vu que j'avais ouvert son
message il m'a envoyé un message il m'a
dit je suis en train d'écrire un papier
avec mon avocat pour lui laisser les
droits pour pouvoir la vendre
j'ai pas pu et j'ai rien compris si je
vais la vendre
il voulait que je lui laisse les droits
de mes cheveux en fait y'a pas de droit
sur des cheveux mais c'est surtout que
les veaux et surtout que les voûtes cd
non c'est pas ça jamais non mais là une
chevelure magnifique qu'est ce que vous
racontez vous écouter on peut tout dire
il ya les vôtres et hier je le vois ces
boucles d'or
le prime de la vérité c'est hier soir
mais ce n'est pas encore dans le
[Applaudissements]